after five weeks at the highest
coronavirus alert level New Zealand has
worked to a partial easing of lockdown
rules until now all non-essential
businesses were ordered to close now
some regulations have been relaxed
allowing other businesses to open like
restaurants and cafes for pickup or
delivery only I've been hanging out for
this it was welcome relief for those
wanting their caffeine fix from a
professional the whole communities come
out and supported us which is fantastic
a few hiccups with the website this
morning but everyone's been very relaxed
it's how we've gotten throat that's good
good to be open again there were also
plenty of people wanting a break from
the kitchen as long lines formed outside
fast food outlets only a handful of new
coronavirus cases are being reported in
New Zealand each day so the government
believes the time is right to begin
relaxing the rules but the message
remains for most people stay at home
there is no widespread undetected
community transmission in New Zealand we
have won that battle but we must remain
vigilant if we're to keep it that way
that includes safely returning more New
Zealanders to work enabling more
businesses to reopen and allowing some
of the recreational activities we've
missed in the past four weeks now it's a
balancing act for New Zealand and
countries in a similar position trying
to avoid a resurgence of the virus while
getting the economy moving again key to
that is restarting stalled
infrastructure projects and as the alert
level was lowered construction workers
were able to pick up their tools again
under alert level 3 the government
expects around 400,000 people to return
to work which will of course provide a
big boost to the economy after five
weeks of inactivity but there is a sense
that even though New Zealand has managed
to control the virus so far economically
the worst may be still to come thousands
of jobs are linked to tourism and right
now the border is closed
the government's own modelling says the
worst case scenario could see up to 26
percent
unemployment's restrictions may be
easing but this country like so much of
the world is a long way from being close
to returning to normal
Wayne hey al Jazeera Auckland